I know how important the citizens are to
the European policy making after all
we are making these decisions to their
benefit however we have not always got
that right this must be this must be
acknowledged now we have an opportunity
to reflect with citizens to listen to
them to connect and engage to answer and
explain to build trust and confidence in
each other between the European Union
and citizens this is an important part
of what conference on the future of
Europe is about diverse MACJC amo la
grande own internal questo projeto
teleconference su futuro del rock in a
dramatist molto Li 800 G to see a quest
for liberty to ecology in la planaria
del the Parliament to vote e
Larry shown shown todavía a quest
approaches the starting point for our
debate on the conference for the future
of Europe is the outcome of the
elections last year 201 million people
participated in the European elections
the second largest democracy on the
globe there is the starting point for
debate so people believe in Europe
people trust in Europe people want to
contribute to the future of Europe the
key question is now does my vote does my
my vote count democracy is based on two
principles on candidates and on a
program you have this Horomia you have
this forum chancellor candidate and for
us it's also important to implement this
on European level for becoming
Commission president for example so the
old debate on the spits in Canada
concept last year
we failed with this idea is still our
interest is EPP and we want to make this
spits in Canada process a binding
process for the upcoming elections in
the European level el próximo nueva
dimaggio so compliance 1/10 anos de la
declaración
Suman kaypro Pinilla la creación de las
Primera's comunidades europaeus a
khaldiya common Sabah UN Aventura
política en el mundo en la historia say
spices le chien Libre meant a you near
sus destinos para grantees are la paz y
mejor r la vida de las personas pero ya
decía que ya declaración que europa no
serie de una sola vez sino a lo largo de
un evolution cos tante que de vida
bazaar say la Solidaridad orang hasta
que nosotros Darley oh no a bump ooh hey
para que la yaani europea kappa durante
faire la paz na europa en el mundo por
eso es la hora de defender la democracia
europay recordar que debemos mejorar la
vida de las personas durante demasiado
tiempo la una des cuidado al pilar
sosial y las politicus economicus new on
ido a company ADA's Demidov Assoc allas
hemos llegado que Crees kelapa brezza
y KO meant a lady Sewall das yes o sólo
puede I meant our loss populace Mo's let
the elección open aman trikha let's eat
open chrome live up maybe Val you know
what mayor de Ferran - you know what an
overlay and the premiere Sean's mom Dora
don't love us on damply Kelly Satori
announced the process is open but school
open up at the Crapo boosts el Lobo in
elite open bull my books heavy - Lissa -
oh yeah I think this debate that we're
having today here is the absolute best
going-away present for Nigel rush for
his last plenary
what better idea then to dedicate the
prime slot off of the week to this
conference what what I think is a bit of
his worst nightmare so it's a shame that
he hasn't joined us here today he would
call this the Federalist plot but it's
happening right here in the open it's a
public debate it's a democratic process
and not for some old ideology but
because solidarity is stronger than
hatred and because cooperation is
stronger than nationalism when we have
brexit a big country that is leaving the
European Union is difficult to say Oh
fantastic we work well no it's a problem
we have a problem when a big country is
leaving Union when five years after the
start of the migration crisis we still
don't have a reform of Dublin we have
problem in European Union we want
citizens to be an interested passive
distant or on the contrary do we want
that their voice really counts and they
can't participate directly in European
democracy I don't only refer to the
elections of members and senior
positions but to ability mechanism in
order to participate in debates and
decision taking we must update the
governance of our democracy the
insufficient satisfactions that runs
through